With a franchise as iconic as the James Bond
series, new entries always come with their
fair share of interesting details. So it's no
surprise that "No Time to Die" is a layered film
that draws from ideas, imagery, and themes from
the series as a whole. Here's a look at a few
small details you may have missed.
1969's "On Her Majesty's Secret Service"
was the last Bond film to genuinely give
Bond hope for true love, in the form of Countess
Tracy di Vicenzo. That film famously ended with
a shocking and heartbreaking death, but Tracy
and Madeleine Swann have quite a bit in common.
Like Madeleine, Tracy was first introduced to Bond
as the daughter of one of the film's villains.
Also as with Madeleine and Bond, Tracy
and Bond's initial intermingling during
a mission transformed into true love. But in "On
Her Majesty's Secret Service," that romance leads
to a marriage that sadly ends with Blofeld
having Tracy murdered, right by Bond's side.
That unforgettable doomed romance has haunted
Bond fans for decades, so going into "No Time
to Die" it was natural to worry Madeleine
might face the same fate Tracy once did.
The film itself makes countless references to
"On Her Majesty's Secret Service," particularly
through the use of Louis Armstrong's "We Have
All the Time in the World" theme in the score,
as well as having Bond once again say the phrase.
"Now we have all the time in the world."
But this time, rather than Bond saying it
to Tracy right before her vicious murder,
it's Bond saying it to Madeleine as he prepares
to sacrifice himself in the film's climax.
It's a reversal sure to wet every eye in
the house, but in a way, it's a touching
turnabout. Tracy's death put a bit of a pall over
the franchise. But here, with Daniel Craig hanging
up the tux for good, Bond doesn't have to survive
losing the love of his life. He's able to die
serving something larger than himself.
On a lighter note, "No Time to Die"
reveals something new about one of
the franchise's most beloved characters. As
is common with Craig's iteration of Bond,
there is a point in the film's second act when
he must go rogue, disobey his orders from M and
enlist the help of Q in better understanding
the film's MacGuffin, Project Heracles.
But when Bond and Moneypenny barge
in on Q after hours at his home,
he's in the middle of preparing dinner for an
unnamed guest. Given Q's nervousness and general
flustered attitude about finishing this dinner
and not being interrupted by Bond's shenanigans,
it stands to reason the guest in question is
a romantic partner of some sort. When Bond and
Moneypenny give him some playful ribbing about who
he's getting so fancy for, he remarks that he will
be here any minute, implying Q is not straight.
Where exactly he lies on the sexual orientation
spectrum is left unspecified, but alongside
the film's overall better treatment of
its female characters, including casting
Lashana Lynch as Bond's 007 replacement Nomi,
the casual assertion that Q is queer is a
charming bit of onscreen representation.
It bears no heavy impact on the plot, but
it's snuck in admirably matter-of-factly.
While the Daniel Craig iteration of James Bond
is canonically an orphan and an only child,
"No Time to Die" features him watching two of his
"brothers" die, with very different reactions.
In "Spectre," we witnessed the controversial
choice to retcon the Christoph Waltz version
of Blofeld to be Bond's adopted brother, the
son of a man who took James in at a young age.
It adds an extra twinge of pathos to their feud,
but it goes largely under-explored in that film
and this one, beyond continuing Blofeld's ominous
speeches about his machinations and grudges.
So it's no surprise that when Bond, while overcome
with rage and choking Blofeld through prison bars,
unknowingly exposes his nemesis to the
nanobot bioweapon that will take his life,
his reaction is mild to say the least.
But he loses another brother earlier in the film:
Felix Leiter, the CIA operative who introduced
himself all the way back in "Casino Royale" as
"a brother from Langley."
"And what about the winnings?"
"Does it look like we need the money?"
Though much of their relationship has taken place
offscreen, with Leiter not appearing in "Skyfall"
or "Spectre," given the amount of time that has
passed in the franchise's world, we know Bond and
Leiter were close. They weren't just work friends,
but rather brothers in arms who had clearly
experienced a lot, on the job and off. Leiter
was one of the only people in these films
who could genuinely call Bond a friend,
so the brother designation is not far off.
Leiter and Bond wind up on a sinking ship,
with Leiter suffering from gunshot wounds at
the hands of Logan Ash, a fellow CIA officer
who betrayed them both. The final moments they
share, as they both have to accept Leiter will
never make it off this boat, is a much richer
and more affecting death than Blofeld's.
But there's a lot of death in "No Time
to Die." None bigger than the last one.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "No
Time to Die" are coming soon. Subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.